اداره نادي النصر السعودي الاستاذ مسلي
المعمر وايضا ينضم لهم مدرب الفريق
النصراوي رودي غارسيه
الكشف عن النجم البرتغالي
ولاعب كره القدم
في ملعب مرسول مبارك مرحبا
[تصفيق]
انا امسك بس
الانتقال التاريخي قال ان الديك الجديد
هذا هو التاريخ الذي نراه ايه وهذا
التوقيت لن يلهم الذين لاحرازين نجحت
كبيره لكنه
انفسهم اهلا وسهلا
في اوروبا
ان تكون هناك في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
اشعر بالسعاده الان انا افتخر
الكبير
في كره القدم
وبكل شيء ولعبت في اكبر الانديه الاوروبيه
بنسبه الان هذا تحدي جديد كما شرطي هو
تحدي في اسيا
وانا سعيد ان النادي النصر منحني هذه
الفرصه
لاعرض واتطور ليس فقط في مجال كره القدم
لاجيال شباب وكذلك الفتيات لي الفتيان
وبالنسبه لنسبه لي هذا تحدي
كبيره وفخر لذلك
اسرتك التي
مستقبلك في السعوديه جدا
[موسيقى]
استقبال بالامس كان مذهلا نحن نشعر
بالسعادهم
وسعوديون كانوا طيبين جدا معي ومع اسرتي
وانا فخور جدا بذلك كريستيانو
ما هي طموحاتك هنا في الملعب وخارج الملعب
في السعوديه كما قلت لك بالنسبه لي هذه
فرصه هائله ليس في كره القدم
[موسيقى]
البرازيل وفي البرازيل وفي استراليا في
الولايات المتحده وحتى في البرتغال الكثير
من الانديه ساعه لي ان تتعاقد معي لكنني
اخترت هذا النادي للفرصه التي منحت لي حتى
اطور ليس فقط كره القدم ولكن الجوانب
الاخرى في هذا البلد الرائع اعلم ما اريده
وما لا اريده ايضا بالنسبه
هذه الفرصه ممتاز انا احترمك
بكل صراحه هل اداء السعوديه في كاس العالم
لكره القدم
وجود هؤلاء اللاعبين السعوديين قد اقنعت
ذلك بالقيام بهذا هذه الحركه والانضمام
الى السعوديه تحصلين على ارقام مختلفه
ولكن هناك من لا اعرف الكثير عن كره القدم
كما تعلمين كره القدم
كل الانديه مستعده وجاهزه لو نظرت الى كاس
العالم لكره القدم همم السعوديه همم
لعبت
وان كان هناك الكثير من الوفاءات كوريا
الجنوبيه والمنتخبات الافريقيه وكوسا ريكا
المنتخب السعودي
ولا يمكن الانكس الضوء الفوز في كافه
المباريات لان كره القدم تغيرته الانديه
والمنتخبات وبالتالي هذا ما دفعني لان
اغير وبكل صراحه انا لا اكترث كثير بما
يقوله الناس سنتخذته قراري
والدي مسؤوليه التحملها لتغيير هذا الوضع
ولكن بالنسبه لي ان اشعر بسعاده غامره
لقدوم الهنا واعلم ان الدوري السعودي
يتميز تنافسيه كبيره
وتابعتهم مباريات الدوري السعودي واعلم ما
اريده وتطلع لالعب بعد غدا اذا قرر
المدرب اعطاء هذه الفرصه ولكنني مساعده
لرؤيتك هنا وفي الملعب ايضا
هناك شيء نتفق عليه هذا توقيع فريد من نوى
ولكن البعض انتقدوا كل الانتقالي الى
السعوديه لكنك قلت انك لا تكترز بذلك ولكن
حدثنا عن هذا الامر انا لاعب فريد من نوعه
ايجابي ان اتي الى هنا لقد حكمت الكثير من
الارقام القياسيه اريد ان احطم ارقام
قياسيه هنا ايضا لانني لاعب فريد من نوعها
وبالنسبه لهذا امر طبيعي
[تصفيق]
كل الانظار هي السوبر الرياضه الجميع
يشاهدون ما هي رسالتك لكافه
انصارك هنا وفي العالم امر باسيجته هنا
لفوز والعب واستمتع وان نشارك في نجاح
البلد والثقافه البلد
وانا موجود هنا مع نادي النصر ومع مدربي
ورئيس النادي وكافه
الاعضاء النصر واريد ان نستمتع بكره القدم
همم لاري زنجر
السيدات
رحبوا معي مره اخرى
بهذا النجم الرائع كريستيانو رونالدو
[تصفيق]
سليم بدايه نبارك لك ولفريق النصر
وجماهير النصر والكره السعوديه هذا هذه
الصفقه التاريخيه وانتم فاوفيتم اليوم
النجم العالمي كريستيانو رونالدو وهو لاعب
فريق النصر السعودي شعورك سعودي ونصراوي
قبل ان تكون رئيس مجلس اداره نادي النصر
السعودي
طبعا الكابتن كريستيانو رونالدو تكلم
بكلام عظيم وجميل جدا من الصعب الواحد
يتكلم
ويقول كلام افضل من الكلام اللي قاله
افضل لاعب في تاريخ كره القدم اللاعب
كريستيانو رونالدو بالنسبه لي هو افضل
لاعب في تاريخ كره القدم طبعا وجود
الكابتن كريستيانو في الدوري السعودي هذا
اضافه لنا في نادي النصر امام اهل الدوري
بشكل كامل الرياض السعوديه همم هذا يعني
نتيجه العمل الجاد والخطط همم يعني تمت من
من سنوات في همم
تطوير الرياضه السعوديه وجود لاعب بهذا
الحجم هذا يدل ان هناك يعني رؤيه واضحه
لنقل الرياضه السعوديه من مرحله الى مراحل
افضل همم هذه الصفقه انا ما اعتبرها صفقه
اللاعب اتى لكي يفوز
في مباراه او في بطوله هي صفقه
ابعد من ذلك هي نقل تجربه
نقل ابداع الهام همم نعرف ان كريستيانو
لاعب مبدع وملهم للكثير من
الشباب والنشا وان شاء الله طبعا بيكون
يعني هو قدوه للنشر في الاكاديميه في
الانديه الاتفاقيه مع كريستيانو لا تقتصر
فقط على كره القدم همم هو دائم لاكاديميات
نادي النصر ومشروع الاكاديميات اللي همم
نخطط لانشائه ايضا همم
التعريف بالتاريخ نادي النصر همم
الدعم القاعده الجماهيريه وباذن الله
تعالى همم خلال الفتره القادمه سيعلن عن
همم
برامج همم مرتبطه بهذه الصفقه للجماهير
للجماهير الرياضيه سواء في المملكه او
خارج المملكه
همم مثل ما ذكرت هي صفقه ابعادها لا حدود
لها ومكاسبها ايضا لا حسره لها طيب همم
سمعنا وقرانا في الصحف وسائل الاعلاميه
والمحليه اخبار وارقام ونسب وتحليلات
وبتاكلات والى اخره حان الوقت ان نسمع منك
تفاصيل اكثر عن هذه الصفقه التاريخيه
الان ما اقدر اتكلم شيء سلبي امام
الاعلامي الاعلام كله موجود
وانا احترمي اجتهادات وسائل الاعلام يعني
هو مجتهدون ويحاولون يبحثون على المعلومه
وهذا حق مشروع لهم لكن طارت اخبار يعني
كثير غير دقيقه واحنا متعودين على الامر
هذا في وسط
رياضي او مع نادي كبير زي نادي النصر او
نجم عالمي مثل همم كريستيانو همم طبعا همم
اا كان في ناس تتكلموا عن اسئله التمويل
التمويل انا اقول وجود النجم بجماهريه
كريستيانو ونادي بحجم شعبيه نادي النصر
ومنافسه مثل الدوري السعودي كفيله استقطاب
اي رعاه او رعاه كبار وهذا بالفعل يعني
عندنا الرعاه الان عنهم خلال الفتره
القادمه الايام القادمه اا
هم يعني تجاريين للصفقه وايضا سيكون هناك
رائع للنادي والعوائد من هذا التعاقد هو
من ناحيه التجاريه هو مفيد جدا لنادي
النصر ولل الدوري السعودي وان شاء الله
الايام القادمه ستظهر تفاصيل وتنفي كثير
من الاجتهادات همم طبعا همم اذا تكلم عن
ارقام الصفقه بالنسبه للنجم مثل كريستيانو
مثل ما سببك وكل هو افضل لاعب في تاريخ
كره القدم طبيعي تكون همم تكون هو اللاعب
الاعلى الاعلى يعني همم
في في العالم وهذا امر يستحقه يعني ما
اعطينا المبالغ اللي يستحقها همم
لكن همم انا بوضح اجانب اخر من المفاوضات
يعكس احترافيه همم
كريستيانو همم اثناء المفاوضات كان من ضمن
يعني
ال- ال- ال- ال- النقاش اللي هو او الرغبه
اللي ابداها ان باقي الامور يكون يعامل
نفس المعامله مع بقيه زملائها من ناحيه
المكافات من ناحيه ال- ال- ال- ال- ال-
ال-
انظمه النادي يكون مثل اي لاعب وهذا امر
لا يستوي طلب منه لانه لاعب كبير لاعب
محترف وهو كل واحد لكثير من همم قدوه
الكثير من النشر واللاعبين في العالم واا
واللي يعني الانديه اللي تعاملت مع
كريستيانو ما تستغرب بالامر هذا منها
النصر له النصر ان شاء الله كل الشكر لك
استاذ مسلي
كوتشاه رولي
كيف حالك انا سعيد للغايه اراد ذلك
[تصفيق]
مع افضل لاعب في العالم
السعودي والمملكه العربيه السعوديه ايضا ل
همم
اضافه رائعه ان ينضم كريستيانو الينا
اليوم
واعتقد
ان لم ارى الكثير من اللاعبين
مثل كريستيانو ولكن هؤلاء
انه علمه كريستيانو
من الامور والاهم من ذلك
لتاكيد ما همم
كره القدم كم خارج النادي النصر على
الدوري السعودي والمنطقه ككل
نعم هو اه اه
مثل يحتذى الكل بذلك هدفي بالنسبه
لكريستيانو هو نجعله سعيده واريد منه ان
يستمتع باللعب مع نادي النصر والفوز مع
النادي ايضا نعم الامر يتعلق به المتعه
هذا صحيح شكرا
سوف يتوجه الان الى المكان تغيير الملابس
للاستعداد للحظه التاريخيه همم
سيد شكرا لحضورك
الينا في هذه اللحظه الخاصه والتاريخ
[موسيقى]